[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: Welcome
to another episode
of "VM End-to-End," a show
where we have a VM skeptic
and a VM enthusiast
come together
to hash out all
things VM related.
Thanks for being
here today, Brian.
BRIAN DORSEY: Happy to be here.
What's the topic for today?
CARTER MORGAN: Oh,
you know what it is.
I need to know about identity.
I need to know about access.
I want to know why I can't
just SSH into everything
or if I can.
What do you got for me, Brian?
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
So a little quickie
bit here, and then I'm
going to bring a
guest in because I
don't know all the details.
So one, you can
just SSH in, right?
It's a computer.
SSH works with keys.
So you've got a key
pair, and it works
as-- when you have that token,
you can get into any machine
that the public key's on.
And you can just manage
those all yourself
if you've got a
system to do that.
But it can get to be a lot
and get quite complicated,
especially as your
organization gets larger.
And we have a way to delegate
the creation of those keys
to Google's identity
infrastructure.
And that is why I wanted
to bring in Emanuel, who's
one of our colleagues who
focuses on identity and access
management.
Welcome, Emanuel.
EMANUEL BURGESS:
Brian, thank you
for that amazing introduction.
How are you today, Carter?
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah, I'm doing
well-- a little confused,
but I think Brian can tell
you where my struggles lie.
BRIAN DORSEY: So Emanuel,
what's the high level
on identity and access
management in Google Cloud?
EMANUEL BURGESS: Brian,
that's a great question.
So let's really go back and
define what is IAM, right?
So IAM stands for Identity
and Access Management.
And so what basically that
means is that you can delegate,
or you can control, who has
access to what resources
in your Google Cloud account.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
So you can get your
who has resources,
or who has access
to what resources.
Who's setting that up?
EMANUEL BURGESS:
Well, so at first,
you need to set up a domain.
And so there's a person
that's called the super admin.
So the super admin goes
into the Admin Console,
and they set up your domain.
And so once they
set up your domain,
it automatically creates
an organization for you.
Now, this super admin is
a role who can do anything
within the Admin Portal.
So they can manage users.
They can create groups.
They can set up
multifactor authentication.
They can do all of these
things via the Admin Portal.
BRIAN DORSEY: So we've got
this super admin and domain.
And the thing I'm used
to looking at the most
is projects.
How do those connect?
EMANUEL BURGESS: Right.
And so a domain one-to-one
maps with an organization.
And so if we think
of projects, projects
sit under an organization.
And so you can really think
of an organization as the root
node within your GCP account.
And so with the root node, you
can have things under them,
like projects and folders.
And then you can assign
resources to projects as well.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh.
And then this
hierarchical structure
is what's used to give access
to different areas, I take it.
EMANUEL BURGESS: Absolutely.
There you go.
CARTER MORGAN: So
then what about
if I want a script or something
to access services-- like,
I want a script to access part
of Google Cloud's resources
for me.
What do I do then?
EMANUEL BURGESS: If you want an
outside application or workload
to access things
within Google Cloud,
you can use what's
called a service account.
CARTER MORGAN: And what's that?
EMANUEL BURGESS:
So you can really
think of a service account
as a special account that's
granted to applications in
order to be able to interact
with APIs within Google Cloud.
And so if we really want
to put this in context,
let's look at a
user account, right?
So if I'm a user, and I
have access to Google Cloud,
I would go via Chrome to
the Google Cloud website,
and then I would log in.
And so when I put in my
username and password,
I'm authenticated.
After I'm authenticated, I
get to inherit the permissions
or roles that are
attached to a group
that I'm assigned to, right?
But if I'm an application,
I can't do that.
I can't go and log
in to Google Chrome.
So I would need
a service account
in order to interact
with APIs and services
within Google Cloud.
BRIAN DORSEY: Got it.
That makes sense.
So we have these
organization units
that give access to things.
If I'm a user, I
can get in one way.
Maybe I can SSH in.
If I'm programs, I can connect
to other APIs via these service
accounts.
Are there any other ways
that programs get access?
EMANUEL BURGESS: Yeah.
So you have service accounts.
And then you also have
service account keys, right?
So back in the day, in
the way, way distant past,
right, we gave outside
applications access
to workloads or resources
in Google Cloud using
service account keys, right?
But service account
keys are problematic.
One of the things that make
service account keys really not
a good choice if you're trying
to really securely build
resources in Google Cloud is
because they never end, right?
They live on forever.
And so service account
keys, if they're leaked,
can cause a really major issue.
And so whoever has access to
your service account keys,
in theory, can impersonate
a service account
and get access to all the
APIs and all the features that
are attached to that
service account.
And then in addition to
that, this causes a secrets
management issue, right?
So how do we manage these keys
that are just floating around?
So now, you have to come up with
a secrets management strategy
in order to
safeguard and provide
some type of peace of mind
around these service account
keys.
CARTER MORGAN: I never
actually thought about some
of these downsides of
service account keys.
And I like just
saying, these things
from the way distant past.
I love that.
What you just talked
about, though,
made me think of something.
It seems like service accounts
are used for resources
within Google Cloud.
What if I have some service
outside of Google Cloud
that I want to
authenticate into?
Is there any way to
let Google manage that?
EMANUEL BURGESS: Well, yeah.
So we can do that.
So let's say I'm using
Terraform, right?
So I want to build
infrastructure
within Google Cloud using a
tool called Terraform, right?
So I can do that.
So long ago, in
order for me to do
that, in order for the
outside application Terraform
to interact with the resources
in my Google Cloud account,
I had to give it service
account keys, right?
And so I would set up Terraform.
I would create a provider block.
I would pass it my
service account keys.
And the service account keys
would impersonate a service
account within
Google Cloud, right?
So that worked.
But now, I can
build my resources,
but now, I have to
manage that specific key.
So now, we can use what's
called short-lived credentials,
and I don't have to worry about
managing these service account
keys.
So now, if I want to
build infrastructure
in Google Cloud
using Terraform, I
can use short-lived
credentials in order
to authenticate Terraform
with Google Cloud.
CARTER MORGAN: I
love how excited
you were to tell me more about
these short-lived tokens.
EMANUEL BURGESS: I love it.
I love it.
CARTER MORGAN: Because
they are that cool.
They really are.
So thank you.
All right.
So but now, to the
question before--
is it possible to get this
kind of security or access
to external workflows?
EMANUEL BURGESS: Well, yeah.
So we also have a feature
that's called workload identity
federation.
And so if you have
workloads that are external
or outside of Google Cloud
that have their own identity
provider, you can authenticate
using these short-lived tokens.
And so what happens is you
have an application who
gets credentials from
its identity provider,
and then those
credentials are passed
to Google's token service.
And Google token service
takes those credentials,
creates an ephemeral
short-lived token
that it passes to the
external application.
And now the external application
can access and impersonate
a service account
within Google Cloud.
BRIAN DORSEY: Got it.
OK.
So we've got a lot of different
kinds of access here, right?
So we've got users, service
accounts, short-lived tokens,
workload stuff.
How do I decide
which ones of these
to use in a given situation?
EMANUEL BURGESS: I mean,
that's a great question.
So it all depends, right?
So if I'm a user, and I just
have a outside application that
doesn't have an identity
provider-- let's
say, once again, I'm
using Terraform, right?
I can use short-lived
credentials
to authenticate that
outside application
and impersonate a service
account within Google Cloud.
If I have a workload that has
an identity provider-- like,
let's say I'm using AWS
for my identity provider,
or I'm using on-premise
Active Directory,
or I'm using Azure
or let's even say
I'm using Okta.
In those cases, it would be
best to use workload identity
federation so you
can dynamically
generate keys and not have to
worry about manually generating
keys from gcloud command line
or one of the other methods.
BRIAN DORSEY: And then
all of this taps into IAM.
Actually, that's awesome.
So you've got a consistent
way to look at it.
That's super cool.
So if somebody wants
to dig in more on this,
where should they start?
EMANUEL BURGESS: In order to
get more information about IAM,
security best practices,
workload identity federation,
short-lived credentials,
you would go
to cloud.google.com/IAM/docs.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
And thank you so much,
Emanuel, for coming in
because I had never heard
of short-lived tokens.
I'd never heard of workload
identity federation.
And I never really thought
about some of the downsides
to even service accounts and
the long-lived static keys.
So to recap, would you say using
IAM is a best practice, maybe,
going forward?
EMANUEL BURGESS: Absolutely.
I think, if you're working
in any large organization,
setting up IAM
using organizations
is really the best way to go.
Now, if you wanted to just
play around with Google Cloud,
you could sign up with
just your Gmail account.
But if you did that, that
wouldn't give you access
to all the benefits of
organizations, right?
So if you're at a
large enterprise,
organizations, to invoke IAM
on your Google Cloud account
is the best way to go.
CARTER MORGAN: Wow.
So that's about all.
I learned so much today
about workload federation,
short-lived tokens, and more.
Brian, Thanks for
bringing Emanuel on.
I got to give you props.
BRIAN DORSEY: No,
thank you, Emanuel.
This was great.
EMANUEL BURGESS: I appreciate
you, Brian and Carter.
Thank you guys for
the opportunity.
CARTER MORGAN: Yes.
If you're listening at home,
leave a comment with something
you learned.
So I learned about short-lived
tokens, workload federation.
What's something that
you learned about?
Thank you.
And that's all for this
episode of "VM End-to-End."
[MUSIC PLAYING]